hey everyone welcome to the first
episode of your daily equation in which
each day I'm going to pick one
interesting influential pivotal equation
that has emerged in our study of either
mathematics or the universe physics
nature and explain a little bit about
what it tells us of the workings of
reality and by the way I should say look
if there are any equations that any of
you have a particular interest in a
fondness for a favorite equation that
you'd like me to say a few words about
just let us know I mean leave a comment
or send an email or everyone to get it
to us I'd be more than happy to take
suggestions as sooner or later I may
find myself running out of equations if
we continue on with this series ok so
for the moment before we actually dive
in to the first equation which is
Einsteins e equals mc-squared I thought
I'd spend just a brief moment saying a
couple words about equations themselves
mathematics more generally so what is an
equation it's a it's a simple sounding
question but one that actually
surprisingly subtle controversial
roughly speaking an equation is a
mathematical sentence a sentence written
in the language of mathematics which
articulates pattern that's really what
equations are all about I mean just give
a couple examples that are familiar to
everyone I would think if you if you
think of the Pythagorean theorem right
you have a right triangle besides a B
and C a squared plus B squared equals C
squared that is a pattern that the sum
of the squares of the two shorter sides
of the triangle equals the square of the
hypotenuse that pattern holds for every
single right triangle drawn on a flat
piece of paper so it's a universal
pattern articulated in a simple
mathematical sentence a simple
mathematical equation similarly if you
have a circle right then area equals PI
R squared again
is true for any circle that you write
down on a nice flat piece of paper and
I'm saying flat for reasons that will
become clear if you stick with this
series because we're going to talk about
curved surfaces where those patterns
then get shifted they get changed into
other mathematical sentences that
capture the patterns relevant when
you're not dealing with shapes that are
drawn on a flat surface so that is what
an equation is but the controversy
arises because people wonder are these
equations out there in the world for us
to discover or are these equations
invented by the human mind to articulate
the patterns that we discover out there
in the world there really isn't an
answer to that question well look there
may be an answer to that question it's
not an answer that I think any human
being currently has at their disposal
right there are some who think that it's
invented some who think that math is
discovered I used to have the opinion
that math was discovered there is times
when you're doing your research as a
physicist or a mathematician and it's
going so well that you feel you're just
sort of chipping away at the obscuring
layers revealing the underlying
equations but other times when it's not
going so well it just sort of feels that
you are inventing or or trying to cause
these relationships to emerge but
they're not out there awaiting you to
find them I'm kind of of the latter
perspective of late for at least a
couple of years I think that these are
ideas that we invent but I think the
bottom line point is it doesn't really
matter from the following perspective
whether these ideas are invented or
discovered they're wonderous right if
they're discovered how amazing that
there are these deep patterns describing
qualities of the world qualities of
reality that that we can find Wow
timeless perhaps statements about the
nature of reality and if on the other
hand these equations are things that
come out of this gloppy gray three
pounds structure sitting inside this
thing that sits upon our shoulders how
wondrous to write that the human mind is
able to come up with these efficient and
economical encapsulations of patterns
out there in the world so either way
it's a it's a beautiful subject math
equations to try to spend a little time
in and that's what we're going to be
doing in this series okay so onto our
first equation for today which is
Einsteins e equals M c-squared so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to talk a
little bit about the history of this
equation a little bit about what it
means what it tells us and then I'll
finish up just trying to give you a
sense of how we can establish that this
equation is actually true right that's
sort of in the end of the day what
really matters these equations are true
okay so for a little bit of history this
equation was written down by Albert
Einstein in 1905 in September of 1905
1905 if you cast your mind back to that
period it was a period of bubbling up of
revolutionary ideas even revolutions
literally right so on the on the
political stage various places around
the world Russia for example the
revolutionary forces are bubbling up in
the art world you've got cubism and
you've got various developments in music
and so forth so it's a it's a period at
least worthy the atmosphere is one of
change of one of revolution and within
this environment within the zeitgeist if
you will
Albert Einstein is working at the Patent
Office in Bern Switzerland why is he in
the Patent Office I think as many of you
know he was kind of a I don't know like
a sassy student in some ways he had no
patience for professors that he lost
respect
for and he didn't hide his lack of
respect for some of these professors so
when he graduated with his degree in
physics and wanted to get an academic
job you know those professors were not
exactly excited to recommend Einstein
for academic positions so he winds up in
the Patent Office in Bern Switzerland
and actually it's kind of a god-sent for
Einstein because it allows him to be in
this interesting middle ground between
theory and real world applications right
what does a patent a patent is something
that somebody's proposing to to build to
make something real that can exist in
the world and Einstein has to think
through the theory behind this proposal
to see whether it holds water whether it
could actually work so he's in this this
wonderful blending of theory and roughly
experiment or real-world applications
and one of the things that people were
focusing upon back then were clocks and
how to synchronize clocks how to
synchronize them so that for instance
trains that are coming from different
locations on the continent don't smash
into each other they need to adhere to a
schedule so the clocks at different
locations need to be synchronized so
he's thinking about clocks he's thinking
about how you might synchronize them and
at the same time there's another
development that's happening in the
world scientists are thinking about
light and it's behavior light and its
properties and one particular
development which it's kind of unclear
whether Einstein literally knew about
this but one development was focusing
upon the speed of light and scientists
were finding that the speed of light was
behaving differently from any other
speed in the world they were finding
that the speed of light didn't depend on
the source of the light it didn't depend
on who was receiving light was a fixed
number and that's that's so strange if I
asked you what's the speed of a car
they'd say like what are you talking
about the speed of a car the speed of a
car it depends upon you know its speed
how fast it's going right and even more
than that the speed of a cart depends on
who you ask if I watch a car that's
speeding by me at 100 miles an hour well
from my perspective that is its speed
but the driver if you queried the driver
and said hey how fast is the car going
well from the drivers perspective the
car is not moving at all it's it's the
outside world that's rushing by in the
opposite direction so there is no such
thing as the speed of a car but yet it
seemed for light that things were
different that there was a speed a very
fast speed and people struggled to come
to grips of this but Einstein he was
this kind of wonderful thinker who would
in some sense look at the simplest
explanation for weird things that are
happening out in the world he said look
you know if if the experiments if the
equations Maxwell's equations which we
will talk about later in the series are
giving a speed for light maybe light in
some sense is behaving differently from
the way you thought speed babe maybe the
light really does have a fixed speed
independent of who's doing the
measurement independent of the source
independent of the receiver so Einstein
comes up with this idea and he runs with
it and he runs with it in a powerful way
and in May and in June in particular in
June he writes a paper on what we now
called the special theory of relativity
and he basically says look what is speed
speed is how far you go divided by how
long it takes you to get there so speed
is therefore a measure of of distance or
space divided by duration or time so if
the speed of light is behaving strangely
in that it doesn't depend on who's
measuring it it doesn't depend on the
source well if it's behaving strangely
then space and time must also be
behaving
Rangeley and so he writes this paper in
1905 and he sends it to a journal the
annals of physics in fact I think I can
if I can figure out how to do this sort
of thing yeah okay there it is there is
the cover of the journal Max Planck was
the editor of this journal and when
Planck got this paper and he turned the
last page he knew that the accepted
scientific order had changed
Einstein had revolutionized our notions
of space and time and in their following
days I'm going to talk about those
equations that Einstein came up with
that time slows down when you're in
motion that length contracts when you're
watching an object in motion but today
I'm going to focus upon a footnote an
addendum if you will to this paper that
Einstein wrote in 1905 there's the first
page of that paper but it's this paper
right here that I really want to focus
attention on because this happens in
September of 1905 Einstein is ruminating
about weirdnesses of space and time all
through the summer of 1905 and he comes
to a conclusion that is so surprising to
him that he wonders in his words whether
the Lord is leading him around by the
nose if the if the lord if the universe
is playing tricks on Einstein kind of
playing a a practical joke leading him
to an equation so surprising that at
first he wonders whether it could
actually be correct and that is the
equation e equals mc-squared and I can
actually show you in this paper on the
final page I guess it's about one to
three or four paragraphs from the end
there
Einstein writes this equation in a
somewhat different way can you see that
L over V squared he writes the speed of
light as a V as we'll talk in a moment
it's a C in the way we usually talk
about L is his version of energy E and
he has mass described in that paragraph
so he writes it and I can actually show
this to you here so Einstein had this
little iPad over
I'm gonna use an occasion right now a
couple of things but Einstein in essence
writes the equation as M equals e
divided by C squared that's his version
of the equation but of course that's the
same as e equals mc-squared
all right there's our equation and I'm
getting a little bit long-winded so let
me now actually get to the equation
itself all right I'm gonna talk about
the terms in here but I'm gonna go not
from left to right I'm gonna go from
right to left it's a little bit easier
so see as I said a moment ago this is
the speed of light and why is it a C
it's the Latin word I think it's
celebrit us although somebody no doubt
will correct my pronunciation I believe
it means Swift or speed in Latin and
that's where that comes from M here is
mass it's the amount of stuff in an
object in some sense it's its heft and E
is the energy that is relevant for the
given situation now energy is a subtle
concept right it's some in essence in
some sense or I should say perhaps the
most familiar version of energy is the
energy of motion right if I'm moving
back and forth there's some energy
associated with my motion if that car is
streaming down the highway it has energy
but energy comes in many forms right it
can also be stored right so if I put
this object up high and then I drop it I
hope you could hear that the energy that
I stored in the gravitational field if
you will was released and when this duct
tape hit the floor it translated to
transmuted some of the energy into
energy of sound other things I don't
have this one all right so this right
you can store energy by stretching
something right so I've used my muscles
my limited muscles to stretch this
spring ething here and now it has energy
because if I let it go
there you see it the energy that I put
in was then able to transmute into the
energy of motion and basically what
Einstein does an e equals mc-squared
he adds one more way that energy can be
stored right it can be stored in in
gravity by lifting something up as I
show it it can be stored in a spring by
stretching it but he says that energy
can also be stored in mass it is stored
in the half the amount of stuff itself
making up an object has frozen energy
locked in energy that he notes can be
transmuted transformed into the energy
of motion and that's what e equals MC
squared is actually telling us now the
most familiar version of e equals MC
squared is of course in in nuclear power
or nuclear weapons right I mean Einstein
is often described as the father of the
atomic bomb as you can see here in this
Time magazine cover and and you know
Einstein was deeply distressed by that
perspective there are many people
involved in the creation of the bomb and
and the point that I'm making here the
scientific point is that e equals MC
squared is not actually only tied to
nuclear forces it's simply the domain in
which the translation the transformation
of mass into energy is most visible
because it's effective at grabbing a
significant part of the mass compared to
everyday processes so for instance if
you have you know in principle if you
have just a couple kilograms of material
because see so if I go back to this
description here so because see in every
day units is such a such a big number
right so C is a fast speed you know it's
three times 10 to the 8 meters per
second 10 to the 8 is a is a big number
on everyday scales or it's always
relative to something else relative to
everyday scales so C squared is a real
big number right like 10 to the 17 so if
you have just you know as a kilogram of
mass you can turn it into a great amount
of energy in principle but it's hard to
do that transformation and nuclear
processes are are pretty good at it
compared to everyday processes and
everyday life but the universality of e
equals mc-squared completely transcends
nuclear forces right I mean a simple
example if you take a flashlight and you
put it on a highly sensitive scale and
you turn the flashlight on the reading
on the scale will go down and down
because the flashlight is emitting light
that light carries away energy if it
carries away energy it carries away some
of the mass of the flashlight and
therefore the scales reading will go
down no nuclear processes at all another
example if you if you have a pot of
water on your stove and you're measuring
its mass say by winging it you turn on
the flame and the mass will go up why
the flame is putting heat it's putting
energy into the water so the water
molecules are now all bustling about at
a higher speed higher energy higher
energy means higher mass equals
mc-squared tells us therefore that that
energy is transmuted to the mass the
overall heft if you will of that pot of
water so that's the the basic idea of
Einsteins equals mc-squared
let me just finish with some sense of
where this equation comes from I'm not
going to give a full mathematical
derivation although it will give you a
link to other videos that I've made
which will take you through all of the
math but let me just try to give you
sort of a feel for where
comes from and one way of thinking about
it is this so Einstein in this modern
version of the story imagines for
instance that we have two masses that
slam into each other and they stick
together and they stick together into a
larger mass now if this one has mass m
and this one has mass m then when they
come together you would think that this
guy that really just sticks together
doesn't emit any other energy no sound
nothing like that no radiation of any
sort would have mass to M that was sort
of the thought that people would have
said you know back in the 1670 1800s
right Lavoisier had this idea that that
mass is conserved he said so if you
start with 1 M 2 M then you have to in
the end also have 2 M but it turns out
that this is wrong Lavoisier is wrong as
Einstein showed because if you are
slamming these two masses together with
a speed V then they have additional
energy from their energy of motion and
where does that energy go when they slam
together and stick together it's kind of
go somewhere if there's no other energy
being released in the process and
therefore that energy of motion needs to
go into the mass of the Amalgamated
version of those particles that their
collision creates so the energy of this
guy is therefore bigger than just M plus
M is bigger than 2m and therefore the
mass of the combined the combined blob
is greater than 2m and the amount by
which its greater has just given by the
energy of motion the kinetic energy of
the constituents that come together so
in some sense you can imagine building
up imagine building up some mass by
taking little tiny masses almost an
infinitesimal amount of mass at rest
slamming them together
slamming them together to get a slightly
bigger mass and then continue to fire
little projectiles together allowing us
to build ever larger material objects by
just looking at one dot after another
one little piece of mass coming together
after another and so you could build up
this guy's mass over here
his total mass is now being built up
from the kinetic energies the energy of
motion of the Constituent particles and
therefore you have this beautiful
statement of the interchangeability of
energy of motion with the material heft
of an object and what equals mc-squared
does it takes that pattern of the
relationship between energy and mass and
it makes it precise in some sense the
pattern articulated by equals MC squared
is familiar from currency conversions
right if you have euros and you have
dollars right there is some conversion
factor that banks in the economic
situation determines that can fluctuate
over time that conversion but the beauty
of the physical version of this is that
the conversion is always the same to go
from mass to energy just multiply by a
particular number the speed of light
squared so again I'll give you for those
who are interested a more complete
mathematical derivation of that in a
different video but that's that's the
basic idea of Einstein's equation and
it's so it's such a beautiful equation
it's so simple
and yet if it is as universal as it
seems to be it's tapping into a deep
fundamental truth of reality something
that that transcends every detail of the
world every detail
of the actual identification of the mass
every detail of the identification of
the energy it all is subsumed in a
beautiful clean pristine economical
efficient equation that describes a deep
pattern at work in the true
understanding the true nature of reality
okay so that's all I wanted to say about
e equals MC squared again I'd love to
hear suggestions for other equations
that you'd like me to spend a little bit
of time on tomorrow I'm going to talk
about time dilation this other weird
feature that emerges from the June 1905
paper not the afterthought the September
1905 paper and after that I'll talk
about Lorentz contraction and then we'll
figure it out as we go forward ok that's
about it that's your daily equation
thanks for joining us see you tomorrow